[Music]
everyone thank you for joining us at
best practices for themes and styles I'm
Alan hi my name is Nick butcher
and we're gonna be talking about some
ways to think about themes and styles at
a high level and how to apply those when
you're designing themes and styles for
your application so first let's start at
a high level the way that designers
create mocks and the way that developers
are interpreting them so here's the
latest iteration of the material design
theme palettes so if you're not using
material design components for Android
yet you may recognize primary as the
color primary attribute from the
material theme in the platform primary
variant as something like color primary
dark and when you get a mock from your
designer you may be doing a mental
mapping of well this is gonna be my
primary dark color in my theme this is
going to be the primary color and
embedding those directly in your theme
but it's important to make sure that
your designer understands that there are
these canonical attributes so if you're
getting a mock that just has a hex color
specified it can be helpful to maybe
push back a little bit and say let's
call this the primary variance or let's
call this the primary color and it's
great that we have all of these
predefined theme colors with meaningful
names and meaningful contrast ratios
that have to exist between foreground
and background and additional colors in
the material palette occasionally you
will get a brand new color that doesn't
exist anywhere and finding a name for
this may be difficult so here we have a
purple color that's a little bit lighter
than our primary variants and it has
contrast against white so we're going to
be displaying white text on top of it if
we want to come up with a name for this
we should find something that can
generalize but is self documenting and
captures these constraints so that if we
decide well we had a purple theme now we
need a blue theme we can reuse the name
of that color and reuse those
constraints so you could move from
purple to blue very smoothly so what are
we gonna call that well Oh
in the material palette we have these on
colors on primary means this is a
foreground color displayed on a primary
background and we ensure that it's going
to meet certain accessibility related
contrast ratios so you'll be able to
read the foreground text color against
the background we have on secondary
which does the same thing for secondary
so if we're displaying something on that
light blue color it would be black text
if we're displaying something on this
purple color it would be white text so
we can use these to generate the new
name for this lighter primary color what
should we call that well we're gonna use
on primary so that determines the
foreground color protection for
background color protection we want to
make sure that it contrasts a little bit
with primary so we'll include both of
these in the name we can call it
something like primary lights which
seems incredibly straightforward and it
is so you can tell your designer hey
every time we're talking about this
lighter version of our primary color
let's refer to that as primary light and
it's going to have these constraints for
foreground colors and background color
protection so if your designer decides
well in this next screen we want it to
be blue instead of purple we can
continue to use the same constraints on
this color and use our semantically
defined color name in our theme as well
alright similarly we provide common
patterns for text appearances so here
you see on the Left we have headline
over line body these are semantically
defined terms they're meaningful names
for where these appearances are going to
be used and that determines the pixel
size that determines the font weights
that can determine the font itself and
that's going to determine the color on
the right we see what these values
actually map to so in this case headline
is going to be Roboto and in fact we're
using Roboto throughout our entire app
however if we decided that instead we
wanted to use let's say Comic Sans we
could make our headline map to Comic
Sans we wouldn't have to go through and
create a new style everywhere in our
application because we do have these
names that imply how they're used so
always make sure to use meaningful names
when you're extracting patterns from
your mocks and applying those in your
implementation
so learn the material design attributes
they're documented at material dot IO
make sure your designers learn them too
and use this as a common language when
you're looking at mocks and when you get
something new that may have a random
gray color in it that you're gonna see
throughout your moths make sure it has a
name that you can use over and over
again and if you happen to be
implementing dark mode for anybody who
attended that talk earlier today you'll
know that this gray needs to turn into a
light white because it needs contrast
against a certain text color or a
certain other background color use
meaningful attribute names they should
be more or less self documenting
something like primary light is going to
have more constraints than just it looks
sort of like the primary color and the
text color should be consistent with
other primary so go ahead and document
these somewhere start a doc that you
share or start an internal site that you
share with your designers to make sure
you're always using a common language
when talking about the components the
colors the reusable textiles in your
designs you'll expand beyond what's
available in material I'm sure but
that's a good starting place to get a
sense of how to name them and how to
talk about them and part of that is
avoid hard coding values so when you get
a mock that just says this is the hex
color for a 360 F make sure that you
push back on that and say no this isn't
a hex color this color has some sort of
meaning and we need to be able to
smoothly transition from this hex color
to a hex color with similar constraints
all right so now Nick is going to talk a
little bit more about what this means in
implementation and key right so we
talked a lot about them and about
supporting different semantical
semantically named values in your
applications and what that means on
Android is essentially it can be
implemented as theme attributes and
Allen says something really interesting
there I said what happens if your design
changes and all of a sudden instead of a
purple theme you have a blue theme and
how do you apply that these semantic
names protect you almost against these
cases and it's actually more widespread
than you might realize and I'll go dig
into that a little bit so if you want to
have areas of your app or screens which
can support this kind of theming there
are different ways you could achieve
this
one way might be that you just you know
say define different styles so in this
one scenario I'm gonna surpass tile to
give it a certain appearance we call
that style one and in another scenario I
want it to look different so I'll give
it another style on style too
the problem with this approach is that
there's probably going to end up being a
lot of duplication between start one and
style 2 and there's now two places for
you to maintain or bug fix or you know
maybe refactor at some point using these
semantical pointers to kind of describe
what the appearance should be like and
or in kind of coding terms it's going to
end up as a theme attribute and protect
you against this so while it we might be
more work to kind of like establish this
language and to set up your Styles to
refer back to female beauty what it does
is it ends up with just a single place a
single style and that will refer back to
the theme attributes defined for a given
theme and the benefits of this is it's
going to reduce that duplication you
don't end up with like two styles which
are 80% the same but you know have the
potential to diverge in the future which
they will and it also localizes the
modifications so that means that if you
need to change an attribute you just go
to that one place where it's defined and
change that rather than have to track it
down where it's leaked out into all the
variety of styles you have across your
code base it also has a benefit I think
of consolidation how many times have you
opened your colors XML file and found 50
different shades of very similar looking
colors and then you see a mark and it's
not quite the same color and you go I
don't know I'll just create another
color resource because it's just me that
is that and it's kind of like protects
you against this you really really
really want to kind of condense it down
to this kind of small palette which is
used consistently throughout the
applications you have a nice looking
film so to sum up basically this
approach really really helps you with
the maintainability of your app and so
as such I really urge you to prefer
theme attributes where possible by which
I mean if you find yourself writing code
like this top line so he's saying the
text color should be you know this color
resource and almost think of that as a
code smell like just think for a second
hang on is there this layout is there
chance this might appear in a different
theme could this be like included in
like a different area of the application
and if so should I be instead be looking
at this bottom form using the question
mark actress in tax which refer it is
how you refer to these theme attributes
so we talked about the importance of
having these kind of semantically
pointers but like how might your theme
vary so hopefully everyone's familiar
that you can set a theme directly on an
activity so in this example two
activities are using material components
which is a dark theme and then a light
variant or perhaps you're using night
mode like an ally mentioned before and
it's also talked about in the cost of a
pixel talked earlier today so this is a
theme which will change between dark and
light depending on the time of day but
what happens if you have a screen like
this which is from and this is a Google
i/o app where we have largely similar
content so most of these list items are
the same but the design called for some
of them to be light on dark I'm Sun to
be on dark on light I mean you can think
of ways you might implement this as
separate layouts or perhaps setting text
colors in unbind or something like that
but both of those basically either
leaking out the sliding information
beyond where you want it or liter and
like an explosion of more and
maintenance instead what you probably
want to do is look at applying themes
the view level rather than ever the
whole activity level and so the theme
attribute was added not theme attributes
the attribute Android Quillen theme was
added in API 21 but also back ported
through Android X so in this you can set
a theme on a view or a view group and
apply a different theme to a subsection
of your view hierarchy and so in these
examples here you might say you have a
light theme and then apply a dark
portion of it or vice versa
you can do the same thing in code if
need be by using the context phim
wrapper which takes an existing context
which has a theme and overlays a style
on top of it I think it's really
important to emphasize that fact that it
is overlaid that means that you have an
existing theme in any values from the
theme you set on top of it are going to
be applied on top so you need to be a
little bit conscious of this fact in
either and you don't want to overlay a
theme which supplies too many values so
for example if I was using just material
components dot light and I overlaid
material components off dark they define
a lot of the same attributes and you
might be relying on some of the
attributes you set in the first theme to
still be present so you might overwrite
too much
conversely you want to make sure the
team you over writing sets the things
you need so as such you might want to
take a look at these team overlays of
which there are some in-app compatible
material components or create your own
female overlays extending from them just
to theme the attributes that you want
such that when it's overlaid on top of
the existing theme you get the resulting
kind of combination of themes one thing
to be note as well is that while the
context cream wrapper approach looks
tent-like tantalizingly close to dynamic
feeling and it's not by which i mean
that you have to apply a theme which
you've defined at compile time you can't
use this technique to say take some
server derive color values or whatever
and create a dynamic theme this is all
about this kind of ahead of time
thinking all right so before you start
setting a bunch of theme attributes it's
important to understand how those are
applied throughout the platform so we're
going to do a whirlwind tour of the
layers of indirection that occur between
what you see on screen and what's
defined by the platform and what your
setting in your application themes so at
any point in your application it's good
to have background understanding that it
you can point it something on-screen and
understand all of the layers of
indirection all of the theme attributes
and styles that were applied to render
it this way on-screen so if we want to
set this color for a single button how
would we do that well let's dive into
the way that this gets resolved at
runtime so we have button defined in
layout XML that gets inflated in the
button class if you watch the
demystifying themes and styles talk that
Chris Bane's and I gave two years ago
you have a complete understanding of how
this works if you haven't watched that
go watch it the important part is that
the button style that you see here is
pulled from the theme that the theme of
the context in which the button is
inflated so relevant buttons style
attribute here at the bottom of the
screen next where is that button style
defined it is defined on the material
theme if we have not redefined it
otherwise so the default value there
that you'll see in themes themes
material XML is widget material button
where do we find the definition for
widget material button over in styles
material so
we can see here the background is
defined to be this button default
material drawable we'll also notice that
right below that bordered ink button
style we have a colored border ding
button style which if we've looked over
the material spec we realized this
probably going to be a little bit closer
because it provides a color in the
button so let's dive into the background
that's used there to see what gets
pulled from our theme and what we might
be able to change in the button color
material XML you'll notice the XML file
names match up exactly with the drawable
names so there's an easy chain that you
can follow we have a shape it's a
rectangle it is colored with a tint
which is our button colored background
material this gets applied to the white
color of the shape so it's got a solid
white fill here so let's dig into that
tint and see what's gonna be applied on
top of that white color it is our color
accents so this is a color state list
it is named button colored background
material XML which is the exact name of
the color that we were just looking at
again a very clear line of indirection
so where does this color accent come
from well because it's a theme attribute
it's gonna come from whatever exists in
our application theme as I mentioned
that inherits from material and if we
haven't redefined color accent to be
anything else it will be the default
teal so here all the levels of
indirection that we've just looked at
some of the important ones are if we
want to change the style for all buttons
that get inflated that's our button
style and the theme that we could set
the button style that we're getting by
default is widget material button we can
change that to something else like
button dot colored in our theme if we
wanted color buttons everywhere we can
also change our color to accent which is
what gets loaded by the colored button
style so if we set that in our theme
that gets used everywhere we'll see that
color everywhere but what we want to do
is one button so what would happen if we
set button style on our activity theme
we would see color buttons everywhere we
don't want to do that what would happen
if we set it in the style attribute on
our button in XML we would see it only
on that single button which is what we
want but now we're getting the default
teal color from our theme so
how can we fix that well what if we set
color accents on our activity theme now
we're getting that blue button but we're
also getting blue switches and blue
everything else that inherits color
accent if you just do a search over the
platform XML files for color accent
you'll see it in a lot of places so
instead we can set it in
we could try setting it in layout XML
you'll notice that this does absolutely
nothing because it's a theme attribute
and you shouldn't try to set theme
attributes directly in layout XML theme
attributes get set in your theme so what
we'll actually do is create a theme
overlay as Nick was just talking about
that sets just that color and contains
nothing else we will apply that to the
button using Android theme in layout XML
and we'll get what we wanted so back to
Nick for more implementation yes so I
said you should prefer theme and
attributes where you can but to do so
you kind of need to know what is out
there what exists and honestly I don't
have a great answer for this for you
other than looking through the Atlas
file of this is from the Android
platform or from app compat or material
components so looking through these
they're not that long you can see what
is available for you that you can
reference rather than hard coding
conversely you can look at some of the
common themes like themes that material
and see which and theme attributes they
set and as such you are able to
reference or override yourself so it's
good to kind of have a look through
these and get an idea of what's out
there one note is that you might see
that some theme attributes are kind of
double defined so the platform defines a
Android you know color control highlight
and then app compat defines its own in
order to provide backward-compatible
functionality so which to use basically
the answer is always if there is one
defined in the libraries like app compat
or material Capone's prefer that because
they all tend to set the platform one
for you and then be available for
backwards compatibility and so on you
can of course refer to these three match
boots in code you're using something
like this where we're doing obtain some
attributes to get ahold of it and then
using K T X's get color or fro to make
it a little bit more convenient so so
far we've talked about using platform
few match boots and you absolutely
should but you can also create your own
and you should do that as well to make
your applications morpheme able let's
walk for example of what this looks like
so here from the dev summit application
we have two screens which display very
similarly
else list of sessions in the both the
schedule and on speaker details they
only differ in basically the how far and
some space of the left and the keyline
essentially that we wanted to align it
to one needs to leave room for the
sticky ahead of time things and so to
accomplish this we defined our own theme
attribute so here this is in artists
file called session list key line and
then in the different activity themes
for those two screens we can provide
different dimension values for that key
line and then we just have to have a
single layout which references that and
that theme attribute using the question
mark atra syntax in order to vary it
without having to create separate
layouts which we then have to maintain
in another place that theming comes in
to the massive handiness
is in teaming drawables so we looked an
example from the platform button about
how from API 20 21 onwards all platform
drawable support tints and tint modes so
here we are applying their color button
normal you can also do this in in
vectors where they support and theme
attributes both for tints as well as for
fills and strokes and so you can use
this not just for 21 words but in the
back was compatible library as well and
if you need to apply tints in the
backwards compatible way to exist built
on prior to 21 you can use drawable
compact like this in order to set some
tints on existing drawable drawable
compact also offers an override which
lets you set a tint list a color state
list to be applied and which is
something we have learned is to be
extremely handy so like the example we
left out before you can define a single
color state this which provides these
different tints and/or colors for
different states so this example is
taken from text primary and one of the
things I love about color statelets as
some of the improvements that arrived in
marshmallow 23 and which allowed you to
separate out the color and an alpha
component and why this is great is
because this really protects you against
that explosion of like 20 different
asset ease of black you might have in
your colors file by actually separating
out the kind of the color information
from the Alpha information allows you to
define more specifically what you want
so here we're saying say this is a light
screen so color foreground will be dark
you can say the text should be black and
it should have these different alphas
depending if it's enabled or disabled in
these two
here so you don't have to have to find
all these different combinations you
defined specifically the semantically
named things like disabled alpha primary
content alpha and foreground possessed
separately and then they get combined by
the color state list at runtime one
thing to note is I've actually cheated
here and changed to the Android alpha 2
alpha because app compat backports this
new function new features added to color
cyclist but it requires you to use app
alpha and one thing to note is that the
alpha channel of the the color and the
alpha are combined and multiplied so be
careful don't specify don't do this
essentially if you specialize this is
like say a 50% white text if you don't
speak X and a 50% alpha you'll end up
with a 25% alford white so you probably
want to refer to colors which have full
alpha and then and only supply variable
alphas by the Alpha Channel separately
and like I said I've compat bakbox this
so use app compat resources to inflate
that in order to get this backwards
compatible behavior and then you can
apply those and to draw balls so overall
if you apply this theming and you can
get to something a state like this and
so on the left these look quite similar
but on the left we have the Google i/o
app and which we fork to create the
android dev summit application and to
reefing it to fit in with the and the
look and feel of this conference rather
than io this is basically the diff
essentially we just had to change a few
of these semantically named colors and
if we go back in this ripples outwards
to all the components so the fab changes
the bottom nav changes some of the tints
on drawables changes the style color
changes like think about if your product
manager comes to you and says hey the
company's had a rebrand and we're
changing all the colors wouldn't you
rather just have a tip that looked like
this rather than trying to go through
every you know layout XML or colors file
and work out which color is which and
where it's used and then can I change
this and where is it going to effect you
really want to like limit the changes to
these semantic or semantic names so it's
a kind of summary of this and really
really like team attribute all the
things essentially use them as it's kind
of like protection and you should
probably like push that kind of semantic
system back upwards to your designers so
they're kind of giving you values that
work with this in your layout xml's
prefer that for you Matt repeat syntax
the question about Actress in tax or be
care
when you're right you're not writing
that thinking is this a smell should I
be doing something else and with your
drawables think about using tints so to
protect yourself against these changes
down the line just think if like all
these are those draw balls have been
pings and said I had to you know we had
a rebrand am I going to have to
completely generate all these pings
again with a new color into which is
already baked into it it can all that
don't do that
use tints instead basically if every
time you use a PNG like think should
this be a PNG is this going to be usable
like or tinted later maybe prefer of
that do prefer vectors pretty much the
only time you should be using PNG is for
nine patches so that's a summary protect
yourself using semantic names and fema
tributo and have fun with themes and
styles
[Applause]
[Music]